MySQL and mongodb are both database
Management systems that let you extract
data and create reports but there are
also fundamentally quite different now
my SQL is a legacy table
based database and that really has a
structured system to it whereas mongodb
is a document
based system
now what does that mean and when should
you choose one over the other well I'll
tell you but first there's something far
more important I want to address which
is where did these Technologies get
their weird names
so you probably already know that SQL
that stands for structured query
language but by the pronoun well
actually it's not the my is a shortened
name of one of the developers daughters
there's also a Maria DB and a Max DB
named after the same developers other
kids
and mongodb [ __ ] that's a questionable
shortening of the word humongous as in
mongodb can store a Hugh Mongoose amount
of data
all right naming aside what are the
differences here well MySQL this was
developed back in 1990.
five and for almost two decades has been
the structured query language on which
the Mainstay of design modeling has been
based for relational database Management
Systems MySQL is table based and
therefore it enforces a schema
and the schema is used so that all rows
in a table will have the same columns
and those columns will have specific
data types mongodb is more recent this
was founded in
2007 and was at the time a new approach
to database design representing data
here as Json
documents so it's object based
hey real quick if you're enjoying this
content please like And subscribe to
this channel now there's much about
these two systems that are alike at
their core both of them are database
Management systems that serve as the
ground level Information Network for any
type of digital site or space both MySQL
and mongodb support the same languages
for example they both support Java
and python
so that's supported by mongodb
and by MySQL apps Developers for both
systems originally created these to be
open source
therefore the code was freely available
for anyone who wants to use and to
distribute it and you could consider
both of these in a cloud native
solution
but mongodb was in some ways designed to
supplant the Legacy MySQL structure as
an easier way to work with data we can
think of MySQL as being a bit more rigid
with its architecture and really not
quite as flexible
for formatting
data
structures as mongodb can be
now MySQL has two main components
there's a type of storage engine and
language used to work with the data so
the storage engine is where the data is
created retrieved sentence stored and
the language is how you access it
mongodb on the other hand is a no SQL
database it's founded upon documents as
the unit of data for search it employs
Json language and it uses mongodb query
language
additionally mongodb employs bison those
are json-like documents that are binary
coded into typically smaller files and
many developers find these easier to
manipulate making data management faster
now which one to use does as always
depend on your use case MySQL is
considered highly accessible and secure
making it well suited to high traffic
sites such as e-commerce sites and
compliance heavy industries that require
protocols for height security
mongodb's use of dynamic schema design
fosses a more flexible environment for
data search coding integration and
database development and it's optimal
for Content Management systems and high
query sites such as analytics
applications
so MySQL and mongodb or you know what
you you could consider a third option as
my yet to be created
giz
Norm
d b
where giz refers to my late cat Gizmo
and Norm for the ginormous amount of
data it can process
yeah this
this needs to become a thing